bienvenidos a un nuevo capítulo de
historia soy álvaro cordero hace 11 años
moamar al gadafi completaba 42 años al
frente de libia con su autoridad
prácticamente y quentin cuestionada pero
en febrero de 2011 manifestaciones que
se iniciaron para pedir más democracia
llevaron a su caída y a un
enfrentamiento armado posterior que se
ha cobrado decenas de miles de vidas y
que dividió al país en varias facciones
enfrentadas entre sí en la crónica de
historia de hoy veremos como libia se
sumió en un caos del que no ha logrado
salir en más de una década las más de
cuatro décadas de gadafi en el poder
tuvieron como pilares fundamentales de
su gobierno al socialismo y al islam en
ellas este militar fluctuó de ser
enemigo de occidente a ser uno de sus
más fieles aliados en la lucha contra
al-qaeda libia era un país relativamente
estable pero el poder que ejercía gadafi
era prácticamente absoluto algo que hizo
que las primeras protestas en busca de
más libertad estallara el 15 de febrero
de 2011 pero gadafi no escuchó los
reclamos de los manifestantes
que orquestó una brutal represión contra
todos ellos
una decisión que trajo consecuencias una
facción del ejército se sublevó contra
el mandatario que vio como en los
primeros meses perdía el control de una
parte importante de libia incluida
bengasi la segunda ciudad de la nación
durante meses las dos partes tuvieron
fuerzas equilibradas hasta que un grupo
de países liderados por la otan decidió
intervenir en favor de los opositores
quienes acusaban a gadafi de haber
atacado a la población civil
quien es responsable el responsable es
gadafi ese dictador ese perro o si ese
es el responsable se acabó si él es
quien destruyó a su propio pueblo esa es
la verdad esta es ahora la historia
trabajar a la entrada de la otan fue
decisiva la ofensiva rebelde fue
fulminante y en agosto de 2011 cayó
trípoli la capital del país pero esto no
hizo que muamar al gadafi -que te diera
el poder dispuesto a luchar hasta el
final se trasladó a sirte su ciudad
natal y el último bastión gadafista aquí
en octubre se libró una de las más
cruentas batallas que finalmente
desembocó en el colapso total del
régimen y el asesinato de gadafi tras un
linchamiento
pero el fin de gadafi no significó el
final del conflicto a la muerte del
mandatario libia se encontró con un
inmenso vacío de poder y un mosaico de
milicias armadas muy diferentes en
aspectos políticos
religiosos e incluso étnicos el gobierno
de transición fue incapaz de hacer
frente a esta situación y se vio
envuelto en el enfrentamiento que
mantenían los militares liberales con
los grupos islamistas que tenían un
poder cada vez más influyente en este
contexto los militares decidieron
nombrar líder al mariscal jalifa haftar
quien apoyó a un gobierno paralelo
formado en la ciudad de tobruk al este
del país bajo su mando se inició una
ofensiva llamada 'operación dignidad que
permitió que todo el este y el sur de
libia quedase bajo su poder incluida
bengasi mientras tanto los grupos
islamistas formaron la coalición
amanecer libio que se instaló en el
oeste y mantuvo la capital en trípoli en
este contexto el conflicto se enquistó y
empezaron a tomar presencia otros
actores bélicos como estado islámico o
al qaeda que llegaron a hacerse con
ciudades como sirte libia se convirtió
en un estado fallido que sirvió de
puerta de salida para cientos de miles
de migrantes que se dirigían a europa
donde se vivió una profunda crisis
migratoria desde 2015 en todo este caos
sobresalió la figura de jalifa haftar
gracias a su poderío militar a
los grupos extremistas islamistas y los
otros grupos y la amistad es que afirman
no ser extremistas como los hermanos
musulmanes trajeron al estado islámico y
los hermanos musulmanes juegan al
inocente cordero que no causa daño pero
es al contrario traen a estos grupos
desde afuera
[Música]
con el tiempo el conflicto en libia se
internacionalizó y potencias extranjeras
comenzaron a apoyar a los diferentes
combatientes la comunidad internacional
se dividió captar contó con el apoyo de
rusia francia egipto y emiratos árabes
unidos por otro lado los islamistas de
amanecer libio tuvieron ayuda de turquía
qatar y sudan y naciones unidas junto
con eeuu y la unión europea creó en
trípoli un gobierno de acuerdo nacional
que sobre el terreno apenas tuvo ningún
tipo de control
durante años cualquier intento de 'alto
el fuego' fue en vano el mariscal captar
siguió siendo el más fuerte en la
contienda y su ejército eliminó la
presencia de estado islámico en sirte y
se dispuso a tomar trípoli para mediados
de 2020 su fortaleza hacía pensar que en
cuestión de semanas todo el país caería
bajo su poder pero no fue así cuando las
tropas de haftar estaban a unos
kilómetros de la capital turquía
intervino de lleno y mandó milicianos
sirios y armamento a la contienda
haciendo que las fuerzas se equilibraron
de nuevo
las tropas de haftar retrocedieron y es
en este contexto cuando tras varias
reuniones el 23 de octubre de 2020 los
dos bandos firmaron un alto el fuego
permanente tras esto se creó un gobierno
de transición que tendría el objetivo de
convocar elecciones para enero de 2022
unos comicios que finalmente fueron
pospuestos por desacuerdos 11 años
después del inicio del conflicto la paz
pende de un hilo en libia algo que hace
pensar que cualquier pretexto podría ser
suficiente para que las hostilidades
vuelvan a esta castigada nación africana
con esto concluimos gracias por
compartir y comentar estas historias que
las encuentran en los programas de
france 24 punto com
[Música]